[Music]
[Laughter]
hey welcome to a very special edition of
Conan O'Brien needs a friend I am uh
thrilled that we are here this is this
is unique this is a real occasion yes
you're all of course familiar with Hans
and fronds
Dana Carvey Kevin Newman's classic
bodybuilder characters from SNL these
were monsters these were monster
characters everyone was doing the Hans
and fronds all across America
uh it was big it was a big deal but a
lesser known fact is that Dana Kevin
Robert Smigel and myself wrote a
feature-length Hans and Franz movie way
back in the year of Our Lord 1991. it
was a musical it was an incredible
vision and it was shockingly never made
you know the only movie based on SNL
characters that wasn't turned into a
movie
no one has ever seen or heard this
script dot dot dot until today I am here
in studio with Dana Carvey Kevin Nealon
hi and Robert Smigel this is the first
time any of them have spoken to each
other since the movie
fell apart
everyone in this room has refused to
speak to each other but now we have come
together put aside our differences put
aside our differences and we're going to
read selections from Hans and Franz the
girly man dilemma
title you probably couldn't use today
Hans and Franz The girlyman Dilemma
remember it was 1991.
sorry we're going to read this more than
30 years after we wrote it gentlemen
first of all I'm thrilled that we could
all be here Dana good to see Kevin
Robert how are you guys doing Kevin I'm
well I'm just Kevin I'm over the moon to
be here yeah to see that you are still
in the business
thank you Kevin stuff that we predicted
in 1991. yeah no it's uh it's nice that
we could come together I wanted to sort
of set the table first before we begin
explaining a little bit of the
background uh of what we're doing here
okay first of all we're going to read
this script about scenes from the movie
we're not going to read the whole movie
yeah the whole movie would be over six
hours long but what we're going to do is
we're going to start by reading an
opening sequence first we have some Team
Coco staffers in the back that are going
to help us with some smaller roles sonum
obsessian Matt Gourley David hopping and
Matt powers are going to be assisting in
smaller roles helping us out I will roll
is too small no rules too no that's not
true some rules are very small
um in fact I'm reading one of the small
roles uh but I'm also going to be
reading stage directions and uh of
course Hans and Franz will be played by
of course by Hans and Franz Dana and
Kevin and Robert you will be playing the
part of uh Arnold Schwarzenegger is that
you're gonna get Arnold What's that
Arnold's here yeah would you like to
meet Arnold we couldn't it's a pleasure
to be here wow
Arnold just walked in this is incredible
dude
finally it's a golden O'Brien needs a
human friend
Arnold amazing that you would just
wander in without even being invited
amazing
and you're so animated
I I can't believe I'm in the studio in
Largemouth I I'm pinching myself settle
down Robert okay all right oh yeah he's
good we don't want him mad at us oh
right right we point out quickly that uh
Robert uh for many many years on my late
night show was the voice in the clutch
cargos of Arnold Schwarzenegger which
was one of our biggest hit characters he
would always come down and uh I would
start interviewing him and it would
always end up with him yelling at me and
you always start with him as well yeah
exactly sort of the beginning
symmetrical yes I thought you looked
familiar yeah Robert
always had this is how low Tech it was
to create a little Gap in his teeth he'd
put a little piece of electrical tape
electric tape in front of his two front
teeth and always in the middle of every
bit it would start to come off yeah and
then we would deconstruct it and I'd say
Arnold your teeth all right don't look
though I have my Gap is delicious how
would we explain this impression to like
Rich Little or something I know
it was an imp I was an imprecisionist
yes exactly I'm a little confused yeah
you said you were going to set the table
when is that gonna happen that literally
set a table Oh I thought we were having
lunch or something
all right so that's what's happening is
uh we should explain to people under 25
who hunts and frogs why
and I think we should we should quickly
and I I know that I have my minders who
are sitting in the room glaring at me
that I keep this thing on the track this
is going to take place over multiple
episodes we're going to read different
scenes and we'll we'll take you through
everything we're going to start reading
the opening sequence in just a bit but
just to tell you Hans and Franz it was a
big deal on SNL Kevin where did the idea
come from go because you uh you were
watching television I believe once
weren't you I was in a hotel room in Des
Moines Iowa I believe it was
Dennis and me and uh I was watching up
close and personal with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and he would talk about
you know what he does when he gets in
the town they're asking what do you do
when you get into town he's well even
though first I get into the nice
shirt I go out on the town I have some
fun then I come back to the hotel room I
get into the nice light card sheets you
know and I called Dane and I said Danny
you gotta watch this and we were both
laughing at it and then for the rest of
the tour drove Dennis crazy we're
talking like Arnold Schwarzenegger and
it was uh
precision and the positivity so I Kevin
told me that I laughed and it was just
it became a poem we did ad nauseum it's
like you get to the hotel you do the
stairs you get a nice light sweat you
take a nice warm shower you put on a
light white cotton shirt and you're
ready for the evening it always went to
you're ready for the evening you're
ready for this we saw the preparation so
you two are doing this back and forth
and then eventually this becomes Hans
and Franz these two characters who want
to pump you up and uh Arnold's cousins
Arnold's cousins and they're constantly
talking about Arnold Schwarzenegger and
became a very popular but also something
else very defensive yes yeah and they
try to cut people down before they mock
them well they're paranoid yeah yeah
aggressive what was it now believe me
now and hear me later hear me now that
was Kevin's hear me now and believe me
you know if you think you're so smart
you know why don't you come and do it we
do no way it's not gonna happen you know
yeah there are on a cable TV show with
like three viewers and they're
threatening them and they never show any
Feats of Strength or lift anything if
you doubt this yeah we can easily easily
very easily come to your house and
you'll see in the script what that we've
yeah Dan and I never laughed more than
we were writing these characters for
hours they were just so fun to do so
then you guys uh and we'll we'll talk
about this how it came about but uh but
we just did didn't we no no how those
are the characters then there was the
idea for the movie right yeah uh way
later yeah it was yeah several years
later and uh I think you guys talked to
Robert and Robert talked to me and we
agreed we would try and write this thing
so let's take you now I think we should
begin
um let's just do a scene see what
happens yeah the stage directions and uh
this reminds me am I Franz and he is
Hans right you know what a while and you
are there to pump okay no one ever knew
which one was Hans and which one was
France okay here I take you now to
Hansen from runs the girly man dilemma
here we go
interior cable TV studio Hans and Franz
two crewcut Austrian bodybuilders with
gray sweatsuits are on the set of their
program
[Music]
the informative training program for the
serious weightlifter wow welcome we're
back
as always don't try to adjust your TV
sets this is our actual song yeah that's
right yeah you're looking at two of the
most massive muscle Gods you'll ever see
in your life yeah because I am hot and I
am France
we followed the methods of our cousin
the greatest bodybuilder in the world
yeah maybe you've heard of him
as they continue occasionally cut to
glazed in different cameramen and
technicians all out of shape hear me now
and believe me later we could easily
grab your love handles and stress them
around you like a bag so you can carry
yourself after the garbage cut too cute
card man holding a card reading yeah
because that's where trash like you
belongs yeah because that's what's like
you belongs
interior a bedroom same Rob Lowe as his
character from Wayne's World is in bed
with a woman she holds remote control
wait a minute keep it on this for a
minute
interior Studio same all right let's
bring out our guest helmet a flabby
shirtless Austrian Man Joins Hans and
Franz he appears painfully resigned this
is Helmut a typical person helmet is
what you would become if you're lazy
interior Rob Lowe's bedroom same nah
this sucks he flips to another Channel
exterior ugly white brick apartment
building the next morning interior
Hanson Francis studio apartment same a
cuckoo clock wakes up Hans and fronds to
sleep in their bunk beds several Arnold
posters hang from the walls many framed
signs with slogans no pain no gain if it
doesn't hurt it doesn't help believe me
Etc music cheerful morning Han slides
out of the top bunk stepping into
France's hand stirrups they are in their
pajamas and weight belts bathroom door
Hans is knocking to come in come on the
France sure your bathroom Franz is
flexing in front of the mirror exterior
bathroom let's go there are some of the
people in this house that need to flex
interior living room later Hans is
watering and being berating a sickly
plant on the windowsill come on you lazy
Channel geranium
whatever that's called grow look how
strong you are yeah I could very easily
pull you out by your skinny Roots yeah
you you look more like a daisy is that
what you want he's yelling and they're
yelling at a plant yes I'm sorry Danny a
gangly nervous dude who lives next door
arrives at their entrance uh guys yeah
yeah yeah a lot can you keep it down I'm
uh I'm just trying to work on my thesis
yeah look how long are you going to be
finished with that yeah yeah you're
going to be needing this quiet business
uh yeah I'm sorry I I just hit on this
whole new verbal Dynamic yeah look we'd
love to chat and engage in Girly talk
but uh now we have an appointment with a
station manager interior TV Executive
Office later two young executives are
seated opposite Hans and Franz everyone
is uncomfortable it's just that Martin
Luther King is a real hero in our
society yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so to
describe him as flabby he is well that's
not the issue what you said was
offensive English please
uh look we've just gotten a lot of calls
and a lot of pressure to pull your show
you pull in our show from television
we're sorry there is a pause look your
suits you sit down and make decisions in
your suits and you don't know what the
people want you know the people your
suits yeah suits so does that change
your mind no exterior TV studio Hans and
Franz Mill about outside the TV studio
dejected this phases of Our Lives is
over it's time to start from scratch
yeah yeah get in touch with that Roots
let's bring a snack share your subway
car later Hans and Franz are in a modern
subway car gnawing on a large ham
foreign
s here's what I can recall I had left
Saturday Night Live and I was out in Los
Angeles working on The Simpsons when
Robert called me and said let's uh let's
write the Hans and France movie well we
had already been writing some of it I
think yeah me and Kevin we weren't going
anywhere with it
it's not like a lot of the early stuff
and I just said I think it would be
great to add Conan to the mix especially
and and the second half with Arnold and
stuff there's so much great details that
you added to this movie that are so
funny he just wanted to keep using the
names Homer and Bart and everything it
didn't go with our script that is not
true this is not true but anyway what I
remember is we've all got together on a
lot was it the switch lot was it it was
Sony was it Sony or
um so we had an office and yes what I
remember most clearly is we would get
there Robert and I would get there and
Dana was pretty proud prompt Kevin would
usually show up just a little late and
at the time you always had a giant Shake
of some kind of oh it was Slim Fast and
you were always sipping on this giant
bottle like a baby I'm still doing it
today yeah yeah I mean also I remember
especially in the early stage you always
have these prepared this prepared food
yeah that was Jenny Craig Jenny Craig
are you serious so you mixed Slim Fast
with Jenny Craig well I I could kill you
but also I had Weight Watchers in my
freezer so I did the three of those and
I gained so much weight yeah
it's like a Mormon diet diet that's
right that's right and the Weight
Watchers women would come to my house
because I would get the VIP treatment
and she didn't know I had uh I had uh
Jenny Craig in the freezer and I love
Weight Watchers and then you know I said
I gotta go to the bathroom I go into my
freezer and get a little Jenny Craig out
and then come back on I thought it was
more like Chinese food and stuff but
didn't you no no he was a thing I didn't
know you guys are keeping track of what
I was eating this is the biggest memory
of the whole strip right let's backtrack
I was never a little late I was the
first one there with Smiggle I don't
remember him being a late type of I
don't even remember you two guys right I
remember
okay now you've gone too far too far but
I uh I was always trying to get time off
from The Simpsons I remembered they
would always keep that writer's room
kind of late and we would try and grab
time on weekends I would try and grab
any time I could yeah yeah to go off to
Sony to work on this ridiculous yes
silly movie uh and one of the things
that a sensible person would have done
if we had been sensible because we're
getting to uh Arnold Schwarzenegger is
to write a movie that maybe Arnold has a
quick cameo in because Arnold at the
time was the biggest movie star in the
world it's what we did what shocks me
now upon rereading it as I remembered
Arnold was in it but I forgot how much
Arnold is in it more than anybody and
so we hung the entire project but didn't
this kind of come from Arnold on some
level like I remember hearing this from
you guys that Arnold wants to be well he
was once or twice he was on Hans and
Franz on Saturday Night Live yeah he
loved it loved it there's reasons why it
didn't work out we can get to those
later yeah yeah but we thought he did
want to have a major party and at the
time he hadn't really done anything like
this yet and he was interested in it and
I remember that I remembered thinking
well if if Arnold also the Allure of if
Arnold says yeah yes this is going to
get made so we can make this as silly as
we want because yeah he's gonna if
Arnold says yes all the craziness is
going to happen exactly and and that and
I also I have to admit that when Dana
and Kevin first approached me with the
idea of doing a Hans and Franz movie my
first reaction was what a horrible idea
because there's such one-dimensional
characters and in theory so my first
thought was well what if we made it a
musical that'll kill like you know 25
minutes right that's less plot and it's
fun to see them sing right and then
these guys said it was you guys had this
idea that they're going to go to
Hollywood and they're going to interact
with Arnold and I was like okay that
makes sense because then the second half
of the movie can be almost like a parody
of Arnold's life right and that was so
much fun that was incredible we got to
create what we hoped Arnold's life was
like in our cartoonist childish brain oh
yeah I mean we'll get to those scenes
like yeah we're coming up on that that's
a big very heavily little Austria was
really made me happy whenever that
emerged was that your idea little
Austria I love that the cable car going
up there yeah yeah yeah
it was fun though it was fun to get
together and work on this thing this was
so much fun just because the characters
are it's like the way you guys say when
you would write these you just can't
stop laughing because they're just so
high energy and so stupid at the same
time well the Rhythm so yeah you guys
are trying to read the script but you're
not very successful are you you know so
you remember that we wrote I mean we all
did but we wrote at that hotel in Santa
Monica that kind of retro place yes I
remember that because I have pictures of
you I sketched of you laying on the
couch playing with your shoe yeah I used
to take when I was when I was thinking I
used to take off your wing tips I used
to wear jeans with old wingtip shoes
from like an army navy store and I would
take off one of the shoes and just look
at it when I was thinking and you drew a
sketch of it which ended up uh in your
book in my book called I exaggerate my
brushes with Fame it's available
wherever fantastic books are sold yep
and that plug is the only reason Kevin
agreed to come in thanks guys I'll see
you later
bro
OD all right let's read uh to the next
scene we're gonna read and we'll begin
right now there we go
after losing their TV show Hans and
Franz head back to little Austria to
start humble new careers there instead
their Grandma inspires them to follow in
their cousin Arnold Schwarzenegger's
footsteps and become Hollywood stars
they also meet their friend Rolf who
seems to be hatching an evil scheme
involving girlyman okay exterior Highway
day Beauty shots of Hans and Franz
riding their tandem bikes on the highway
a sign reads Hollywood 3063 miles they
notice it and press on determinedly
Frost dissolve Hans and Franz biking
grim-faced with passing road signs
Smithsonian Institute Liberty Bell
Gettysburg Memorial they ignore them and
ride on the next sign reads Vienna
Wonderland they turn off the highway
dissolve to exterior Highway later they
are back on their tandem bike their
knapsacks are stuffed with large bulky
corny souvenirs okay what loser am I
what century did you live in 19. how
flabby were you I was 40 pounds
overweight Luis Pastor you're getting
too good
all right one loser am I will you
pass shaped or completely round
and I want to play that game all right
exterior
exterior small town laundromat day Hans
and fronds pedal up to the entrance
interior laundromat same Hans and Franz
are in their long underwear shoving
their sweatsuits into a washing machine
a few nearby customers hold their nose
cut to Hans and fronds later removing
their sweatsuits from a dryer they have
shrunk noticeably oh this is
unbelievable yeah yeah this is not the
proper size an older woman at the next
dryer has noticed them that's what
happens these machines you put your
closed captioning not available
[Laughter]
I wouldn't want to have to kick anyone's
head in
yeah
don't take your shirt off or your belt
because you might cause a flabber lunch
I guess we should take this outside they
get up to leave and start backing out of
the lines yeah very clever we're going
to Palmer you and end up in jail I don't
think so yeah I still have Easter babies
we're headed for Hollywood they're at
the door turning back wait a minute yeah
what now did you say Hollywood exterior
Highway Hans France the older woman and
the three truck drivers are pedaling on
the tandem bike which now has six seats
and six wheels okay interior Lair
Twilight music impending doom Blair is a
cavernous dark room with a network of
ramps leading to different levels Rolf
walks past the crew cut uniformly clad
Muscle Man goons standing guard he hits
a control panel and turns in his swivel
chair to face a large screen distorted
colors on the screen vibrate from the
disembodied voice of Mr X Ralph's
mysteriously there Lieutenant Roth
reporting to Mr ax
how is a plan to kidnap girly man and
convert them into muscle man proceeding
you're a very slow talk
everything is in place
very well that the plan into motion
remember I want choice
it shall be done and don't forget to
hurt
the environment
I think I heard you correctly you said
don't forget to hurt the environment I
told you oh man wow
God damn
Ralph is petting a button marked hurt
environment he laughs villainously our
six bikers led by Hans and Franz with
passing highway signs Mount Rushmore
Yellowstone National Park Grand Canyon a
road sign with a picture of a large beer
stein Reed Stein Museum featuring Herman
the German Glockenspiel the bike turns
off the freeway
exterior Stein Museum day Hans and Franz
are exiting with their friends all armed
with new souvenirs and Steins they turn
a corner and enter screening room day
interior Roger Ebert let's just some
older references here Roger Ebert famous
movie reviewer had a show uh originally
it was Cisco and Ebert yeah Roger Ebert
is watching the Hans and Franz movie
taking notes Hans fraunting their
friends all enter how do you like it
holding up quite well wouldn't you say
well not much has really happened yet I
didn't think two sketch characters
what part are you up to angle on the
screen Ebert is up to the beginning of
this scene with Hans and France entering
and asking of questions angle on Hans
and Franz watching the scene with
interest
yeah this is this is the this is the
good part right here listen to look at
this yeah this is very enjoyable yeah
all right everyone is here let's leave
him alone yeah let's go they noisily
exit Ebert's size then looks to camera
it is good
oh man good Lord that is low
exterior Highway later the tandem bike
rolls along it now carries 10 people
including a businessman a 10 year old
girl and the cartoon-headed mascot from
the Stein Museum dissolved to the tent
and bike approaching a signed reading
entering Hollywood Hans removes a large
pin from behind his seat disengaging
hogs in France from the rest of the
tandem bike which splits into eight
different unicycles the others disperse
expertly pedaling in different
directions
Hans and Franz wave once more than
triumphantly ride past the sign
wow okay all right that is now Hans and
France have arrived in Hollywood that
seems as good a place as any to stop I
completely forgot because I really liked
it now it was a nice surprise I
completely forgot that they visit Ebert
whose reviews this is like my favorite
reviewing the movie as it's happening
I guess I forgot that until I looked at
the script again I always loved the
unicycle thing where they keep taking
more and more people on the tandem place
this part of the movie was very Peewee a
big adventure influenced yeah and then
the second half I think is more
simpsonsy yes where it becomes a parody
of Hollywood but what's funny about the
way you guys edited this talk about old
references so that scene in the diner
was like a parody of the famous it was
meant to be a parody of the famous scene
in Five Easy Pieces where Jack Nicholson
wants a certain kind of sandwich
yeah yeah I want you to take the bread
and I want you to substitute the
anabolic steroids whatever it was hold
it between your knees I think was the
thing yeah and that was in there too I
wanted to hold it but um it's just so
funny that's how old that reference is
that even your guys didn't pick up on it
but it was a Five Easy Pieces memory
from 1973 with Jack Nicholson there's
also some Charlie Chaplin things you cut
out yeah that's true every day starts
with me telling my staff who I am
I had a late night show in the 90s
but you know when we're reading this I
could just picture it like when we were
writing it it's almost like you could
visualize it what you've done already
like picking that little pin up and
letting the unicycles like oh you know
if I was a director I'd have a close-up
on it I do think that's great that it's
funny with the sound off I mean I think
that was probably all intentional
obviously because our voices have thrown
in Brea gadocia is one lane but then all
these physical gigs yeah so I'm glad
that you reminded me Dana you brought up
a really good point which is Hans and
Franz do a lot of boasting and a lot of
flexing and a lot of talking about how
they're gonna twist the flap around you
but when confronted by a trucker who's
saying hey is this guy giving you
problem you guys are in his face and the
minute He suggests a fight yeah you have
you want no part yeah
right
right who those I give you kudos for
your attempt yo do you know why you're
here now on this scene because we wrote
the scene for you
don't don't press your luck my friend
yeah press 20 pounds maybe if you
threaten us we could threaten you back
and then walk away all pumped up here
and you have to look it up
I go open up the back doors of your
truck and believe me fat would come
rolling out with love that's right
you should wear a fatty hat
all we did was scratch the surface here
uh this was our first episode you've got
to stick around because in the next
episode Arnold Schwarzenegger himself
enters the scene of course uh he ended
up not doing that I wouldn't I know this
is Hackney but I would not want to miss
the next episode no can I just tell you
uh when Arnold Schwarzenegger came to
SNL to be in the first SketchUp I
remember that yeah first of all we
couldn't believe he wanted to do it
because basically we're making fun of
him yeah and then we realized he's
coming on the show to kill us and he
came and got us that day yeah and we
were on the set and they brought us to
his dressing room and his name was on
the door and it was so long it went onto
the wall a little bit you know and we
opened the doors full of cigar smoke
remember that day oh yeah it's his
lounge chair he's got a big cigar one
cigar I wanted him to script he wrote
from the other and he looks through the
cigar smoke to us and he goes hello
fellas now how am I supposed to do the
accent
yeah right then we do is cool yeah
because he's he's like I said Arnold is
very pragmatic Yeah the more they they
doing me on the show and it makes it
better that I can laugh with myself you
know other other actors are very serious
but they see the joy and the comedy it
opens up a whole new world for me yes he
was well this is he went on to be a
governor he had political instincts he
used a lot of the uh Hans and France
references too he did he did yeah I got
in trouble for it New York Times wanted
to interview me I was on a camping trip
but they said what does girlyman me
what are you trying to say I mean it
came such a big part of Pop Culture even
the astronauts in the shuttle were doing
we want the bomb you love oh and gyms
everywhere don't be a good early man I
mean even in Argentina and some of us
the horses were doing it and mules were
all right I'm gonna break it off there
Kevin's going on one of his famous
tangents let's get him his pills uh
we're gonna be back you gotta stick
around for the second episode uh we are
reading uh Hans and Franz the girly man
dilemma the movie that was never made
that was written in 1991 we've got Dana
we've got Kevin we've got Robert Smigel
and myself but not Arnold we'll see
we'll see if he shows up next time stick
around for that next episode yeah wow
foreign